james stinson the manager of this car
wash was a viewer he saw these fugitives
for the last 11 days he knew what they
looked like he saw that car that truck
right there parked in the bay that did
not move he thought it was weird he saw
something he said something he actually
went up and inspected that vehicle he
actually opened the door of that vehicle
he checked to see the keys were in the
vehicle and thought it was weird he
moved the vehicle because it was
blocking one of the car wash bays and he
called the police and the police at some
point stopped by ran the plates and
decided it wasn't stolen and that was
that
but he didn't stop there he looked at
his security camera video he saw that
figure you could see him lurking back
there that's casey white back there and
you know something this manager knew
that his tattoos matched up with the
tattoos he'd seen on tv
so he persevered and he got that
information to the u.s marshals and you
have the result you have now james
stinson is a hero and james stinson is
now with me live sir congratulations um
i don't know how important you think you
are but if it weren't for you i don't
think any of this would have happened do
you realize how significant the role was
that you played
no not really i didn't intend to be a
hero
and i kind of figured out it was him i
had to hunch with him
i was concerned about a single local
police officer stopping him somebody
getting hurt i kind of figured it would
end up in a high-speed chase a gun
battle a shootout luckily no nobody was
hurt other than in the people that done
this
so my question to you is when you saw
that
suspicious truck sitting in the bay of
your car wash and it didn't move for a
very long time you dropped your i think
your granddaughter off at school yeah
you picked the granddaughter back up and
all that while that trunk was there how
nervous were you when you approached the
truck to take a better look inside
i was really nervous because with the
tennessee plates and i already heard
that the suv was abandoned in tennessee
and i kind of uh slowly walked up to the
truck and kind of glanced over thinking
somebody could be in it maybe asleep
would raise up or passed out or even
dead
nobody was in the truck so i opened the
door the keys are in the ignition
i started the truck the truck started
fine so i knew there wasn't nothing
wrong with the vehicle to it being
abandoned that's when i went back and
looked at my cameras and i seen his
tattoo on his arm i pulled a video up on
my cell phone of him down in alabama and
the tattoos matched
and that is you
doing citizen sleuthing because that's
exactly what the us marshals determined
is that those tattoos were a match even
though it was very hard to see that that
was the suspect casey white so mr
stinson
did you see anything inside that truck
when you got in to get it out of that
car wash bay did you happen to notice
any uh wigs or any clothes or any
receipts or anything that looked sort of
unusual in that truck
no no i didn't but the police officer
that walked up and looked inside it he
said oh my god there's a gun lock he
said but i don't see a gun
he did see a gun lock i'm assuming the
gun lock belonged to her most law
enforcements have gun locks
so and he said told me he said there's
nothing i can do about it it's not
reported stolen and that's when i said i
can't i'll have it told
so that's how it wound up so you drove
yeah so you drove it out of the bay you
call the wrecker and all the while are
you a little bit frustrated that the
police haven't shown up on mass to
interview you about you know your
surveillance tape and what you saw like
this i mean this was a week ago yeah
absolutely i i was
one go in and show them the video and
say look at this guy he's and you could
see him acting suspicious i said
there's got to be something to this
i mean it's it defies logic that you're
so close by
you call in a tip and it's a good tip
and no one you know descends upon you
know your house or your place of
business to ask you a bunch of questions
and ask to see your surveillance tape
this all could have been wrapped up
maybe a week ago and vicki white might
not be dead if this were a week ago
you know where i made my mistake i
shoulda i got to give thanks to the news
media y'all the ones that brought this
to an end because when i called y'all
y'all got the ball rolling
so can i ask you about that reward money
mr stinson the uh it's you know when i
came to er i thought it was about
fifteen thousand dollars but brian anton
our correspondent who you did an
interview with uh earlier live on news
nation uh he says it's up to about 25
000. i'll bet you could use that money
oh yeah yeah that's that's a big plus
but i'm not i'm not so much concerned
about the money i'm just glad nobody
else got hurt other than
the victims
do you have a message for casey cole
white tonight the fugitive they now have
behind bars
stay where you're at
stay put
it's a good one
mr simpson i hope you get the reward
money i think you deserve it you're an
amazing person and you know but for your
diligence uh we might not have casey
white behind bars and the public at
large might not be as safe as they are
because of
you my motto and i heard it from our
local prosecutor nick herman if you see
something say something
everybody
thank you so much
well and i'm glad you did because it led
to what uh where we're at tonight so mr
stinson thank you so much